video games they can be exciting big
action-packed things or they can be
interesting little experiments and today
we are going to look at one of those
games it's a pleasure and an honor to
sit here next to a Robin Hunicke and
Keita Takahashi from phenomena and Robin
you worked on Journey
Keita you're well known for Katamari
Damacy and but today we're looking at
what Tom I played this back at judge's
Week and the best way I can explain it
is a relationship playground is that at
all accurate that is okay I think the
game the game does defy description
because that phenomena we try to push
the boundaries of what games can be but
what we're trying to do with this game
is thread the needle between the
structured gameplay of something like
Katamari which has really explicit goals
and a timer and the open-ended
playground of Nobi Nobi boy which has
almost no goals and is just about like
exploring the systems that exist so
we're right in the middle awesome so
let's jump right in so we can show
people what I saw a few weeks ago that
totally surprised me make it happen this
is the backstory fortunately
so we're looking at as a
post-apocalyptic survival and you kill
everything cut yeah it's the story of
this little mayor that wakes up on this
cube the last little piece of what was
the planet but it was so young when it
happened it doesn't remember anymore and
so now it realizes that might not be
alone figure out how to make some
friends and not just be alone on the
planet all by itself so we'll see
evidence of this in a second but this
game is a lot about interacting with you
know putting two objects together and
seeing what transpires when there's a
connection there
so yeah I guess let's take a look so
Kate is just gonna play through the
beginning of the game in which we show
you how the world works you climb you
can hold hands and when you hold hands
with people you make friends say hi
you can also DJ kind of between the
characters on the right stick on the
controller this is a major thing you
move the character realistic but you're
cutting switching around between with
you right and if you want to you can let
go or you can just hold him so this is a
perfect example of if you play through
the tutorial exactly like it says you
wouldn't be holding hands of the Marek
but you can kinda not listen and do what
you like during the game which is the
way that Kate likes to play Kate likes
to play open-ended systems that are
really open and alive I might sell them
a little bit more of a rules follower
but I do really enjoy being able to push
and see what happens yeah and if you
guys still defining you know the
limitations and the extent to which you
can experiment yes I think that some of
some of the stuff that's been going on
that we've been working on lately is
mostly about figuring out how to make
climbing and stacking really fun but
also kind of instant
Jania Slee rewarding in a way that is
not typical so you know normally if you
climb something you just get to the top
and then with Tom we want you to be able
to climb something and then do what Kate
is doing which is stretch and climb and
then make things happen inside that big
stack okay it's not easy to do a lot of
physics with arbitrarily shaped
characters I've spent a lot of time
working on the system being able to make
what we call soft or wobbly stacks sure
and again like you know normally you
solve the problem you just make
everything a box and you put it on top
of each other and then you don't
simulate we're making this game we've
been really trying to make it as natural
filling as possible
so this is the core mechanic of the game
make a big friendly friendly stack or
chain and then you explode it and it
causes basically like almost like a
flare to go up yeah and that explosion
sound is so exciting that it attracts
other people who have been blown out in
the atmosphere and are waiting to come
home and said this is going to mean that
the mayor has more friends which is
really fun it's fun for the mayor mayors
need constituents he hopes that you will
also enjoy the explosions yeah and so
far we've only seen the mayor some
flowers but there's a large cast of
objects and items and characters yeah to
behold I don't think we're going to be
able to even scratch the surface today
but we should be seeing something new
pretty soon it great yes so what's gonna
happen right now is you'll notice the
person is arriving from outer space so
this is actually a person and what you
didn't realize when you started was that
the person you were on top of is alive
so that little area of grass with the
tree on top is the person there's a new
person coming in so the level kind of
builds itself as you play and you've
just unlocked this lovely lon and on the
lawn is a mower and the mower has a
really intense power which is it can mow
people mow grass
you'll also notice that the mower is
named Nathan everyone in the game
currently is named after the dev team
and our friends and family these are all
the characters you can unlock by you
play Nathan is our creative director
over it so when you say Monica a really
great guy and when you finally play with
Tom on your own PlayStation the names in
the game will be based on your friends
and not just my playstation but also on
your Facebook so we really want to
connect to your social networks and
allow you to experience the joy of being
them you know the flower of the mower or
possibly some of the other characters of
the game like say the golden that
suddenly the golden poo is named after
my mother yeah essential crisis was
really wanted to get to so you can see
that Keita enjoys just having fun
playing with the physics of the game but
also there's like activities so for
example this is an activity where you
can just mow it sounds great it feels
great and if you do it enough you
actually unlock a special character this
is one of my favorite characters in the
whole game it's a golden lawnmower it's
what we call a luxury item because it's
gold and when it mows it spits out coins
so we had a more like that make a lot
more games but basically what we wanted
to do was to build this environment
where if you want to play and Experion
sort of experiment with different
characters making stacks and doing crazy
physics stuff you can if you just want
to hold hands and make a long chain of
people you can do that too but the cool
thing about the game is that you don't
have to play by yourself
so I could for example go into this game
and I think this will just work there I
am Hey look at that so now I'm the other
character in the game
kata still controls the camera so the
camera will automatically kind of keep
us both in frame but I can go over here
and hang out with him so I'm going to
try and climb up on him Hey look at that
again make it bounce so um I could also
yeah he could control the mower and you
could blow me I can come down here and
take this character and come over here
and make a friend and then kata can make
a big friend group and now we have an
explosion group that's 12 people and
this new dude is saying hey if you make
an explosion of 10 that will make me so
happy so if we do it we will attract any
person to this world and you notice that
the explosions in the game are super
super super joyful very explodey not
even nearly as beautiful as they will be
in the final game but we really wanted
to build this game where you explode
bring people together which is
counterintuitive but when you play it it
kind of makes me yeah yeah so the mayor
is actually experiencing the scent of
the new person
what happened was you saw the front lawn
and now you're gonna get the kitchen
table from the mayor's house and there's
a whole epic backstory much like there
was with Katamari that comes from the
genius okay his head in which he's
created all these characters so I guess
at this point now that we've kind of
done all the exposition kata you should
share with the viewers some of the
things that you think about this game
like I can't talk the whole time you
would like that well I know you like to
play with your son right yeah yeah how
does he feel about the game he laughed a
lot I'm gonna party here answer I'm
missing the music with this yes that's
actually something that we should talk
about kata and Brad who's the sound
designer it worked super hard to come up
with a system that allows you to mash up
the different sounds of people so any
person that Kate is controlling right
now has their own unique sample and as
you switch between them you're kind of
DJing the samples in the environment and
in a sense what you're doing is you're
creating a dynamic mashup of all the
music in the game it's kind of like
there's a song that's created when two
people connect and then that song
changes over time and one of the things
kata does say about the game is that you
know the world is filled with all
different kinds of people if you were
all the same shape if we were all just
blocks it'd be pretty boring and yet
when you look at the way that I'm gonna
go over here if you look at the way that
we live and on this planet what causes
the most explosions is usually the
differences between people different
ways we feel about it you know each
other our religions our color and he
even says our favorite games here these
are really serious issues
which lead to some kind of conflicts but
if we were able to see past our
differences and work together to create
awesome things wouldn't the world be a
better place alright so let's try to do
you know how I was talking about my
mother being or the pooping name yeah my
mother
Bruce is my father it's been Bruce this
whole time the resemblance is uncanny so
you know one of the things that happened
when we showed this game to you guys the
judges day was that we were we were
really nervous because this is the first
time we've ever shown what Tom to
anybody and you know it's not done yet
it's hard zoom in on that it's hard to
understand no I can't okay yeah Frost
yeah we didn't know how people would
react to it because it is fairly
flexible you can play it exactly the way
we tell you to play it or you can just
do whatever you want like climb a tree
because you're a toilet and the reaction
that we got was was really really
heartwarming and the thing that we loved
about it the most was that people really
could just laugh and have a good time
playing it in a way that any when was
last time that a game really cracked you
up it's actually kind of hard to make
something that's super funny Oh truly
genius I thought he's really he's really
good at not taking himself or the game
too seriously and that allows you to
have fun when you play it yeah during
that event like it we walked into you
guys had like sort of a geodesic teepee
walked in there and didn't really know
what to expect I had high hopes and 20
minutes later there was like a group of
10 huddled and there's laughing
hysterically and really enjoying
themselves which is something that you
don't get from a lot of today's games
that are just so see they're trying to
be so serious yeah well and this is the
other thing is that I think many many
years ago now
kaida was asked to be on a panel of
games that would change the world and
his presentation was in order for games
change the world they would have to
provide food water and power and equal
rides to like everyone on the planet and
that's gonna be a lot harder for games
to do then say just
and entertaining a few people so maybe
we should be okay with the fact that
what we do is bring joy to people
because that's good that's important so
one of the people that we would like to
bring to a2 is actually the pillow this
is a sad story about our boss character
it was extremely sad outside
unfortunately they have a special power
which is that they they have the
opposite of the Midas touch they put
everything that they touch to sleep
which is a very lonely place to be and
so basically what you find out through
this cutscene is that this pillow
character this one's friendly and loving
miserable sad person and I think this is
probably the most epic moment in the
whole game right here when the pillow
becomes a teenager and is so sad that
everyone runs away from it it's just
like what is going on pillow just wants
out some friends so I don't like the
rest of us well I think this is a pretty
good moment you're at this demo although
I'd love to watch you play along now you
know actually if you want to see the
rest of it you should come by the booth
play it there are so many fun characters
in the game it is so it is so
interesting and and good for us to see
people play it and understand how they
play with them
KYNA you should close out the interview
by saying something about what time what
do you think I'm trying to make yeah
very seriously you have time well if you
have opportunity it's faith when all
this stupid game be out when it's stupid
enough I like that answer a lot kay done
Robin thank you very much for joining us
to see more of this stay tuned to more
GameSpot saved in a GameSpot for more
III news maybe some more about Tom who
knows thanks for joining us everybody